hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to one hour with mr. hop now
if you remember mr. hops Playhouse I
don't think that's the name of the game
but that's what I'm calling it cuz I
can't remember the actual name it was
the dab licks in go you can do a come on
don't be shy it's still alive its 2020
come on bring it back what's he do it
just listen come on just do it
so the creator of mr. hop or mr. hops
playoffs or the house of mr. ARP or
whatever that was decided to make a
small little game for Halloween of 2019
and I didn't know about it until just
now so I'm gonna give this a try it's
supposed to be well oh it's supposed to
be a five nights at Freddy's stop
well what who who what why that's a
problem
I'm assuming that was a problem did I do
something good did I do something bad
don't don't don't what am i doing
Oh No okay so it's a five nights at
Freddy's die wait a minute
okay so I'm supposed to find him he's
food no no no no no see the thing is
about mr. hops play us it is it was
scary hey hey get out here is it was
actually quite scary it was pretty scary
and a lot of love
where are you where are you I don't know
where you are I'm assuming I killed you
no no this is fine
well I don't know I'm fine though
there's no need there is no need my
incredible five nights at Freddy's
instincts are kicking in super hardcore
right now and you were not gonna give me
mr. hops no matter how much you want to
get out of here you loser
you stupid idiot if you think that you
can even come close to getting me
whoever you wait a minute hi
that was much creepier than I thought
it'd be oh my god stop for just a small
game that was made for Halloween this is
actually a surprisingly well made little
Horgan he's gone here but it's only one
hour so I'm assuming I'm doing pretty
good doing pretty alright I just got a
well alright go I don't know where you
are
did I do it I don't know if that means
that hey bud okay yeah I don't know if
it means that he's actually here if it's
just my flashlight going wibbly-wobbly
okay
thirty minutes we're doing so good hey
okay so this isn't so bad this is
actually not that bad it doesn't seem to
be maybe it is I was about to say it
doesn't seem like it's getting any
harder but mayhap mayhaps it just might
watch run wait wait did I get him oh god
did I get him or do this other thing
where I went by and he's now well it's
too late now this is actually pretty
creepy I can wait I got it I gotta give
the developer here props this is
actually surprisingly well spooky
not a lot of spooky it's it's just a
little spooky I only need 20 more
minutes nineteen minutes actually it's
like way
mr. Hobbs I also do know that the
developer is making mr. hops food
whatever that would be
15 more minutes no no that's but I don't
know if I'm just owning myself
mr. hops was one of those games that was
just eerily scary like there was
something inherent about it that was
just really creepy from the characters
designs the idea to the childlike
innocence of the death that would be
fallen five more minutes I can't lose it
now okay where you at where you at Bubba
where are you at Bobby boo where UI
Bobby where you at Bobby you only got
two more minutes four minutes
easy easy and then I'm out of here I'm
so out of here one moment easy easy
[Music]
who gets up at 4:00 a.m. all right okay
easy easy I got a gold star I don't see
it here all right let's try hard how
much harder could hard be hey buddy oh
hey buddy hey buddy okay you are you're
a little more active than you once was
no I mean he's here what's the deal oh
there's a lot of flickering happening I
just don't know if the flickering is to
be combined with the idea well that he's
here hey you're really who's that
wait what was that that was different
okay all right okay
hey all right mr. Hobbs all right okay
all right listen listen mr. Hobbs I well
there you are huh mr. roffe's you are
kind of a douche sometimes so uh I'm
soon I'm so kind of curious of whether
it was actually all in this kid's head
or if mr. hops really is a demon a demon
bunny from out of this world that there
ma that's kinda tough it's kinda tough
it's really tougher toffee toughie big
ol boobies puff alright so that's how
it's gonna be I just I think what I
gotta do is I gotta keep cycling no
matter what because if I don't stop
cycling he's gonna find me and I won't
see him so I just gotta keep going I
just gotta keep it cycling baby keep it
cycling and when I keep it cycling the
King never gonna sneak up on me okay
just gotta keep cycling baby keep
cycling there he was oh yeah this is the
strategy okay I know this is a lot of
motion for a lot of little commotion but
you know it's just this is the only
thing I think this is gonna be a
surefire way of winning this I don't
know why I want to win this but I want
to win this oh [ __ ] okay they it counts
only counts knowing a little bit learn
it a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit and then I got you okay
just gotta keep cycling that's what I
call [ __ ] all right let's go again
let's go again baby you think you're
better than me answers that you are not
I think I might have been cycling a bit
too quickly because I must have been
overlooking something okay there you are
yeah I think you have to keep it on just
a little bit longer than just blasting
him for a moment it's got to be on him
for a bit
oh yeah there he is okay
there's got to be a bit more thorough
[ __ ] oh god that was him oh boy
whoo boy oh boy
hoo boy mr. hoppy who is a hoppy who
ain't too happy god this is this is
absurd
this is uh this is obscene and absurd
this is absurd
no where's he it's been a little bit he
calmed down and I don't trust it
I don't trust it at all not a hundred
percent sure about the whole drawing MN
thing from the noises but whatever maybe
maybe that's my problem I'm just a
little too slow okay twenty-two this is
the best so far oh [ __ ] oh okay he's
gone I guess okay alright just one more
try one more try one more try it's easy
to lose III think it's just like a
misstep if you go like two away it'll be
a problem or if you go a little too fast
I start to get a little to be delicious
after a certain amount of time oh god
that's how you sneak up on me that's how
it's gonna happen
that's how I'm gonna die okay I'm really
focusing now I'm surprisingly focused
I'm very focused I want to get this why
no idea
why why I was so fast I'm really trying
to be fast I I really am maybe I'm just
too fast maybe that's the thing maybe
maybe I need to focus less on up there
he was maybe I need to focus on less on
going under the bed I say as he appears
under the bed and going back and forth
between the top him maybe maybe I don't
need to change until I've until the
light flickers maybe that's my problem
I'm moving too soon I need to stay here
coz there's only one place he to be here
okay and then check here and there yeah
I only need to move when the things are
happening that's that's it that's the
trick when the light flickers I react to
that that's the trick I was trying to be
all pre-emptive in getting ahead of the
curve but that's not how you do it
you got to react okay yeah this is it is
totally it guaranteed it so it this is
it boom that was it easy enough okay I
got this though I know the strategy now
it's getting a bit tight but I'm almost
at 30 minutes okay there's the guy it's
pretty much as soon as it starts
clicking I can go I think
yep cuz it'll either catch him there and
okay it's it's just like it's good it's
it's fine it's all good thirty minutes
easy oh yeah there is an gone easy-peasy
I don't know if there's like a he'll get
you if you don't get the toys in a few
seconds but I'm just gonna treat it like
everything else and get there as fast as
possible it ain't nothing there st.
nothing easy
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah gotta beat him now what the [ __ ] was
that about there oh god maybe I wasn't
like moused over him all the way so
weird my I think the game's bugged out
it's not flashing anymore it's just like
static yeah oh god no oh god my game is
bugged that's some [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] right there I am I'm gonna get
out of the game and I'm gonna go back in
just because it's super bugged but I'm
gonna be this okay here we go
hard mode baby well I guess he was there
okay this time I'm feeling pretty
confident I say as I get ready to drop
the ball harder than I've ever dropped
it I says I get ready to choke harder
than I've ever choked ain't gonna be
more disappointing than when I blow it
right at the finish line if I can do it
for 20 minutes I can do it for 59 and no
more that's where I'm gonna draw the
line that's why they call me not cross
the finish line mark thirty minutes just
enough time to contemplate my inevitable
doom
25 minutes to go 24 minutes is all the
distance I need to fail oh my god that
was close that was actually closed oh my
god he's speeding up he's speeding up
he's speeding up I'm actually gonna blow
it I'm actually gonna blow it I'm gonna
blow it 20 minutes left and I'm going to
blow it here I go it's it's blowing time
B to blow any chance of success away ten
minutes oh my god I'm gonna [ __ ] it up
oh my god I almost [ __ ] it up
oh no six minutes Oh No
don't give me hope okay I got it okay
that those goals for men's oh my god
please don't oh my god let me actually
have this okay okay okay okay okay okay
that was a lot harder than I thought
it'd be
I really psyched myself up for failure
there I really thought I was actually
gonna screw it up I legitimately did but
that is one hour with mr. hop on
hardmode baby boom not so bad so the
developer moon bed Studios is making a
sequel to mr. ops playoffs or whatever
it was called
I'm not Harvison sure but look forward
to that coming whenever it comes out
which might be a while who knows
honestly but thank you everybody so much
for watching if you haven't seen mr. ops
Playhouse or whatever it was called I'll
link it in the description with the
proper name attached to it click right
down there if you want to see it it's a
good horror game very very nifty if I do
say so myself and if you want more scare
games there's also a big playlist full
of scary game for you to check out down
there below as well thank you again
subscribe for more bring the bell if you
want to know when that more is coming to
you leave a like if you enjoyed the
video and thank you so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]